nos preguntan es x 3 un factor de y aquí
nos dan un polinomio de cuarto grado y
aquí podías hacer la división larga de
este polinomio entre x menos 3 y
verificar cuál es el residuo si te
encuentras con que el residuo es
distinto de 0 entonces x menos tres no
es un factor del polinomio pero si el
residuo es igual a cero quiere decir que
x menos 3 divide exactamente al
polinomio y por lo tanto es uno de sus
factores tenemos entonces que el residuo
es igual a cero si y sólo si es un
factor es un factor y conocemos una
manera inmediata de calcular cuál es el
residuo cuando divides un polinomio
entre una expresión de primer grado como
está más precisamente un polinomio de
primer grado como este me estoy
refiriendo al teorema del residuo para
polinomios el cual establece que si
tienes un polinomio pd x el cual lo
divides entre un término digamos x menos
a
esto implica que r el residuo es igual
al polinomio evaluado
y cuál es a en este caso en este caso a
es igual a 3 evaluamos entonces el
polinomio en x igual a 3 si obtenemos
que es igual a 0
entonces el residuo es igual a 0 y x3 es
un factor si al evaluar el polinomio en
3 obtenemos que el residuo es distinto
de 0 entonces x menos 3 no es un factor
entonces qué es lo que tenemos veamos lo
voy a hacer en magenta aquí van a venir
muchos cálculos esto es 2 que multiplica
a 3 a la cuarta que es 81 menos 11 que
multiplica a 3 al cubo 3 al cubo es 27
vamos a tener que hacer algo de
aritmética hubiera agarrar un ejemplo
más fácil más
15 por 3 al cuadrado que es 9 + 4 por 3
que es 12 qué suerte por lo menos estos
dos últimos términos se cancelan que es
lo que nos queda ahora a partir de aquí
es pura aritmética 2 por 81 es 162
- 11 por 27 veamos
27 por 10 3 270 más 27 es 297 menos 297
si se viene este cálculo veamos 27 por
10 270 más 27 297 si está bien
finalmente más a esto hay que sumarle 15
por 99 por 10 90 más 45 135 más 135 135
y esto cuánto nos da si sumamos 162 más
135 esto es 297
- 200 no lo va a poner mejor en verde
menos 297 lo cual es igual a cero así es
que el residuo al dividir este polinomio
entre x menos 3 es igual a 0 lo cual nos
confirma que efectivamente x menos 3 es
un factor del polinomio